SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO --
TALLOW [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
THEY WIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
THEY GIVE IT SECRETARY MEMBERS
IN OUR GAS BEYOND THE RAIL
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
CAN YOU ALL PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LEADING PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN PASTOR JOSEPH
C. SACK OF THE SINNER PRAISE
MINISTRIES AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE IS
AFTERNOON.
BY SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SERVICE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND A SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. FOR THE INVITATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN PRAYER.
GRACIOUS LORD WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THIS DAY.
IN FOR LIFE AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE.
WE TAKE THIS TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE GREAT WORK OF YOUR HANDS.
AS OUR VERY BEINGS ARE MADE IN
THE IMAGE AND LIKENESS OF GOD.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE PROGRESS
MADE IN THIS NATION AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL PEOPLE BEAR
THE IMAGE OF GOD.
WE THANK YOU SPECIFICALLY DURING
BLACK HISTORY MONTH FOR THE
LEGACY OF INSPIRATION
[inaudible]
INNOVATION PERSEVERANCE IN
VICTORY ACCOMPLISHED BY AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND AMERICANS.
IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
AS YOU A LORD WITH A SOURCE OF
STRENGTH FOR THE OPPRESSED AND
GENERATIONS PASS.
WE ALL STAND IN NEED OF YOUR
STRENGTH AND GUIDANCE TODAY.
WE PRAY FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
CONTINUE TO DO GOOD WORKS. TO
REAP WERE OTHERS BEFORE US HAVE
SOWN.
AND TO BE LIGHTS IN THE DARKNESS
OVERCOMING EVIL IN ALL ITS FORMS.
LET US FORGE AHEAD INTO A FUTURE.
THAT IS BEFITTING OF THE
SACRIFICES SUFFERING AND HARD
FOUGHT VICTORIES OF THE PAST.
IT'S IN YOUR HOLY NAME WE PRAY
AMEN.
IN HONOR OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL JOIN ME AND
SALUTING THE FLAG THAT
REPRESENTS FREEDOM FOR ALL.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC WITH HIS
HAND [inaudible] ONE NATION
[inaudible]
AMERICA INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY
AND AFTER KERR.
THANK YOU SIR.
WELCOME BACK SENATORS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A PHOTOGRAPHER WILL BE
ALLOWED ON THE FLOOR FOR TODAY'S
SESSION.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO KICK OFF
WITH SENATOR BILL MINING IT WITH
OUR FIRST INTRODUCTION PLEASE
SENATOR MONEY.
CENTER MONEY WILL BE WELCOMING A
VERY SPECIAL SET OF GUESTS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
JUST WANNA LET OUR GUESTS GET A
CHANCE TO GET IN HERE AND BE
RECOGNIZED.
HE COULD.
ALONG WITH THAT [inaudible]
SPREAD OUT.
JEFF YOU GUYS DURING THE MIDDLE
NAME.
OKAY FILM BACK IN.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS.
I'D ASK THAT YOU PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING TO THE SENATE
CHAMBER TODAY AN IMPRESSIVE
GROUP OF STUDENTS FROM MY
DISTRICT WHO ARE ALL STUDYING AT
CAL POLY STATE UNIVERSITY IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO.
THIS DELEGATION CONTAIN SOME OF
CAL POLY'S MOST EXCEPTIONAL
STUDENT LEADERS.
INCLUDING MANY WHO HAVE ACHIEVED
EXCELLENCE IN DISCIPLINES THAT
RANGE FROM ENGINEERING
AGRICULTURE TO THE LIBERAL ARTS.
MANY OF THESE STUDENTS HAVE
ACHIEVED SUCCESS IN NATIONAL
COMPETITIONS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
FIELDS OF STUDY.
AND THEY RECEIVED NUMEROUS
EDUCATIONAL AWARDS AT THE STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVEL.
THE STUDENTS ARE JOINED TODAY BY
CAL POLY'S PRESIDENT DR JEFFREY
ARMSTRONG WHO JOINED WITH BY HIS
WIFE SHARON TODAY HE HAS SERVED
AS PRESIDENT OF CAL POLY SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN AND UNDER HIS
GUIDANCE AND LEADERSHIP.
CAL POLY HAS CONTINUED TO PROVE
ITSELF AS AN INCUBATOR FOR
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE FRIENDS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
PRESIDENT IN THIS OUTSTANDING
GROUP OF STUDENTS TODAY.
THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
LET'S GIVE THESE UNDER YES A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE IN WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO WELCOME ALL
OF OUR GUESTS TO PLEASE STEP
TOWARD SENATOR MINING FOR A
PHOTO.
ALL SENATORS ARE WELCOME AS WELL
.
MUSTANG PRIDE HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS.
GREAT TO CD MAJORITY LEADER
EMERITUS IN THE RIGHT COLOR
TIGHT TODAY'S WELL
.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
SENATOR BRADFORD IS PREPARED TO
TAKE UP HIS ITEM.
HE IS.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ OKAY SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWELVE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD RELATIVE TO BLACK
HISTORY MONTH CENTER BRADFORD
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS IT'S RIGHT HONOR TO
PRESENT.
AS C. R. TWELVE IN RECOGNITION
OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
A CELEBRATION THAT STARTED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX BY CARTER G.
WOODSON.
AS NEGRO HISTORY WEEK.
I WAS TOLD TO AND IT DIDN'T
BECOME BLACK HISTORY MONTH UNTIL
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHEN.
GERALD FORD RECOGNIZE IT AS A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
AND I WAS TOLD IN HIGH SCHOOL
THAT.
THE REASON FEBRUARY WAS PICKED
BECAUSE IT WAS THE SHORTEST
MONTH.
IN THE YEAR.
BACK IN THE BAND ANYTHING
FARTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
THE REASON FEBRUARY BLACK
HISTORY WEEK WAS INITIALLY
PICKED.
A MONTH AFTER THAT IS BECAUSE IT
COINCIDED WITH.
MISTER WHAT SINCE TWO HEROES.
SLAVE ABOLITIONIST FREDERICK
DOUGLASS.
AND PRESIDENT ABRAHAM LINCOLN
WHO SIGNED EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION SO TODAY AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I'M HONORED TO STAND HERE.
A CAUCUS BORN OUT OF THE EMPOWER
COLLECTIVE VOICE OF BLACK
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN CALIFORNIA
SOME FIFTY ONE YEARS AGO.
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND AND NOT A
NINETEEN WILL MARK FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS SINCE THE FIRST ARRIVAL OF
AFFERENTS TO PRESENT DAY AMERICA.
AND IT'S STORED HERE TO EACH AND
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT AFRICAN OF I
MEAN AMERICANS OF AFRICAN
DESCENT HAVE MADE TO HELP SHAPE
THE CULTURE ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC AND MORAL.
ATTRIBUTES OF THIS NATION ARE
UNDENIABLE.
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT
LIFE WOULD BE LIKE IF THERE
WEREN'T ANY.
BLACK PEOPLE. FOR INSTANCE WE
WOULD PROBABLY STAND IN THIS
CHAMBER.
LIT BY CANDLELIGHT IF IT WASN'T.
FOR LEWIS LATIMER WHO CAME OUT
WITH THE FILAMENT FOR THE LIGHT
BULB IT WASN'T THOMAS EDISON.
AND ON THOSE HOT DAYS WHEN WE'RE
ABLE TO FLIP A SWITCH AND ENJOY.
THEIR CONDITION WE SHOULD THANK
FREDERICK MCANALLY JONES WHO
INVENTED THE AIR CONDITION UNIT
HORROR AS WE DEBATE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND WEATHER PREDICTIONS IT WAS
DUE THE ALMANAC THAT WAS CREATED
BY.
BENJAMIN BANNEKER WELL BEFORE
SCIENTISTS WERE TALKING ABOUT
WEATHER PATTERNS IN IF YOU EVER
NEEDED A BLOOD TRANSFER --
INTO A TREE TRANSFUSION WE
SHOULD THANK.
THE LATE DOCTOR CHARLES DREW.
AND AS YOU APPRECIATE YOUR COLES
AND BEING ABLE TO THE HOME IN A
DRYER HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR GEORGE
SAMPSON WE WOULD STILL BE
HANGING HIM ON THE LINE OUTSIDE.
AND AS WE ENTER BUILDINGS WOULD
GRADY'S LET'S REMEMBER OSBORNE
DORSEY WHO INVENTED THE DOORKNOB.
AND AS WE TRAVERSE MULTI IF.
OF FOUR BUILDINGS WITH THE EASE
OF SIMPLY PUSHING A BUTTON.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER ALEXANDER
MILES WHO INVENTED THE ELEVATOR.
AND FOR ALL THE LIVES COUNTLESS
LIVES LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN SAVED
IN A FIRE BECAUSE THAT A FIRE
ESCAPE LADDER.
LET'S REMEMBER THE NAME JOSEPH
WINTERS.
AND FOR PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF WHO
ENJOY THE GAME OF GOLF.
IF IT WASN'T FOR GEORGE FRANKLIN
GRANT WE WOULD STILL PROBABLY BE.
STOPPING OUR HILL AT THE ON THE
GROUND AND BUILDING A MOUND OF
DIRT TO TEAR APART BALL IT WAS
GEORGE FRANKLIN GRANT WHO
INVENTED.
TO COPY THIS AND SO MUCH MORE
YOU ENJOY DO YOU SEE AND YOU
MARVEL AT ITS WONDERFUL.
ARCHITECTURAL GREATNESS WE MUST
REMEMBER THE SLAVE.
AS YOU MARVEL AT OUR CAPITAL IN
OUR WHITE HOUSE IT WOULD SLAVE
LABOR WHO BUILT.
THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
NOT ONLY TODAY BUT EVERY DAY WE
SHOULD CELEBRATE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND TALENTS
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
I AM OFTEN FACED WITH THE STARK
CONTRAST SAID AS AMERICA IS
LEARNING.
AND PROGRESSING AND COME TO
TERMS WITH HIS PAST AND HOW TO
DIRECT ITS FUTURE WHEN IT COMES
TO EQUALITY IN HEALING WE STILL
HAVE MUCH WORK TO DO.
IN FACT I THINK OF THE TIME WHEN
I WAS FIRST ELECTED TO THE
GUARDINO CITY COUNCIL IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AN
INDIVIDUAL CAME.
TO ALL COMMUNICATIONS ANY STATE
AT THIS IS THE DARKEST DAY AND
GUARDINO HISTORY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN INTERNAL
OBLIGATION AS LEGISLATIVE BODY
TO PROMOTE RACIAL HARMONY.
AND WRITE THE HISTORIC WRONGS OF
RACIST POLICIES IN HOUSING.
LENDING POLICING AND THE LIKE.
WE MUST BE VILLAGE IT VOTERS
CHEN.
AND STEADFAST IN OUR PURSUIT OF
EQUALITY.
AND EQUITY FOR EDUCATION
ECONOMICS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
FROM SLAVERY TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
HANDS THAT ONCE PICKED COTTON
NOW PICK PRESIDENT AND ALSO ARE
HAVE BEEN PRESIDENT AND WILL BE
AGAIN.
BLACK HISTORY IS AMERICAN
HISTORY THAT TELLS STORY OF WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE AN AMERICAN.
NOT UNTIL WE TRULY EMBRACE OUR
PAST GREATNESS.
OF OUR PRESIDENT AND OUR FUTURE
MEMBERS AMERICA IS GEAT AND
WILL REMAIN GREAT BECAUSE OF THE
ENDLESS CONTRIBUTIONS.
OF OUT AMERICANS OF AFRICAN
DESCENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE FINANCE ARE.
AT SEA ARE TWELVE THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA GO TOWARDS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE WE WILL GO IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER SENATOR PAN.
DIRTY LEADER HERTZBERG CENTER
LEYVA.
IN CENTER MITCHELL CENTER PAN
FOR SOURCE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS I TO RISE IN
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF US SEE OUR
TWELVE AND AS VICE CHAIR.
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WENT THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM GUARDINO FOR
BRING THIS FORD.
EVERY FEBRUARY WE REFLECT ON HOW
BLACK AMERICANS HAVE PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN SHAPING U.
S. HISTORY.
AND WHY MUST BE REMEMBERED THESE
HISTORIES.
THAT'S BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED THE
PAST STILL AFFECTS OUR LIVES
HERE TODAY.
AND IF WE DO NOT REMEMBER WE RUN
THE RISK OF FORGETTING WRONGFUL
CHAPTERS IN OUR NATION'S PAST SO
THAT WE MAKE WE MAKE AND MET THE
SENS AGAIN.
WE MUST HONOR THE HISTORY OF
RESISTANCE LED BY BLACK
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY BUILD
UPON THIS LEGACY.
MAY THE RIGHTS AFFORDED TO ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
TODAY EMERGE FOR THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT THAT WERE LED BY
BLACK AMERICANS.
THIS HERE SAW THE POLITICIZATION
OF ASIAN AMERICANS AS WELL WHO
TOOK THEIR CUES FROM THE BLACK
PANTHER PARTY TO ORGANIZE
PROGRAMS TO FEED AND CARE FOR
THE PEOPLE.
OUR CAUCUS RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING
COALITIONS AND SHOWING
SOLIDARITY ON RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES.
SHIRLEY CHISHOLM THE FIRST WOMAN
AND BLACK AMERICAN TO SEEK
NOMINATION FOR PRESIDENT UNITED
STATES REMINDED US HOW PROGRESS
IS MADE.
HE SAID IF YOU IF THEY DON'T.
GIVE YOU A SEAT AT THE TABLE
BRING A FOLDING CHAIR.
SO WITH THAT AYE AYER URGE AN
EYE ON ACR NINETEEN AND AGAIN --
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH AND AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM GARDENA.
THANK YOU CENTER PAIN MATURE
LEADER HER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
PRESIDENT THE RESOLUTION BEFORE
US.
S. C. R. TWELVE RECOGNIZES
FEBRUARY IS BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
IT IS BEAUTIFULLY WRITTEN.
IT TELLS AN IMPORTANT STORY OF
OUR HISTORY AND RECOGNIZES THE
EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTIONS
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE MADE. TO
THIS COUNTRY.
WELL THE ESSENCE OF THIS
IMPORTANT TRADITIONS FINDS ITS
ROOTS BACK TO NINETEEN TWENTY
SIX AS INDICATED BY THE AUTHOR.
AND IS YOU ALSO INDICATED IT
WASN'T UNTIL PRESIDENT FORD WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS OFFICIALLY DESIGNATED
FEBRUARY IS BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
I CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO SOME OF
THE WORDS OF THAT RESOLUTION FOR
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WERE
CONGRESS DECLARED THAT IT WAS
QUOTE CALLING UPON THE PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES TO OBSERVE
THAT THE MONTH.
WITH APPROPRIATE CEREMONIES AND
TO SALUTE ALL BLACK AMERICANS
WHO HAVE DONE WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE TO HELP BUILD OUR COUNTRY.
S. C. R. TWELVE ECHOES THE
SENTIMENT AND CELEBRATES THE
EXTRAORDINARY BENEFITS CONFERRED
ON US FROM THE WORK OF THOSE WHO
CAME BEFORE US.
IN OUR OWN JEWSH TRADITION WE
TAKE [inaudible]
TIME.
ONCE A YEAR TO HONOR OUR
FOREBEARS TO HONOR OUR MOTHERS
AND OUR FATHERS AND OUR
ANCESTORS AND OUR LEADERS.
WE TAKE THIS TIME TO TELL AN TO
RE TELL THEIR STORIES TO PASS ON
THE THEIR LESSONS AND TO KEEP
THE SPIRIT.
OF THEIR ASPIRATIONS ALIVE.
IN THE NEXT GENERATION.
THE STORIES WE TELL THIS MONTH
THE HISTORY HONOR.
REMINDS US THAT WE STOOD ON THIS
FLOOR NOW.
EACH DAY.
AS WE ENTER THIS BUILDING IN
THIS CHAMBER WE CANNOT FORGET.
THE SHOULDERS UPON WHICH WE
STAND.
NOR THE SACRIFICE AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THOSE WHO CAME
BEFORE.
IN WHEN IT COMES TO THE STORY OF
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
IN AMERICA IT ISN'T JUST THE
GENIUS OF FREDERICK DOUGLASS OR
THE ELOQUENCE AND PHILOSOPHY.
ENCOURAGE OF DR KING WE MUST
REMEMBER.
BUT AS THE AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE CORRECTLY NOTED EARLIER
THEIR INDIVIDUAL NAMES MANY OF
WHICH I'VE JUST CROSSED OUT IN
MY REMARKS BECAUSE HE MENTIONED
THOSE BUT I'D LIKE TO ADD THE
NAME OF GARRETT MORRIS.
WHO INVENTED THE TRAFFIC LIGHT?
AS WELL AS THE GAS MASK USED BY
FIREFIGHTERS DOCTOR SURELY AND
JACKSON INVENTOR OF THE TOUCH
TONE TELEPHONE AND THE FIRST
BLACK WOMAN TO RECEIVE A
DOCTORATE.
IN THE MASSACHUSETTS INSTITUTE
OF TECHNOLOGY.
WILLIAM PURVIS THE INVENTOR OF
THE FOUNTAIN PEN.
AND OTHERS THAT WERE EXPRESSED.
THE STORIES WE TELL THIS MONTH
THE STORIES OF PEOPLE WITHOUT
HOME ARE WORLD WOULDN'T BE THE
SAME.
OF PEOPLE OF ALL THE FABRIC OF
AMERICAN LIFE AND IN DOING SO
HAVE BOUND US TOGETHER INCHED
INDELIBLY.
TODAY IS A DAY TO CELEBRATE THE
STORIES AND THE RICH COMPLEX
HISTORY THEY EMBODY IT IS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY IT IS
OUR HISTORY IT IS HUMAN HISTORY.
YES FOR THE GREAT ARCHBISHOP
DESMOND TUTU WHO SAID.
MY HUMANITY IS BOUND UP IN YOURS.
FOR WE CAN ONLY BE HUMAN
TOGETHER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND
CELEBRATING BLACK HISTORY MONTH
I ISSUE AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER SENATOR LABOR.
CENTER DORADO CENTER MORLOCK
DINNER WIENER IN CENTER MITCHELL
CENTER LABOR HE FLOOR IS YOURS
MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
AS A CHAIR THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. YEAR TWELVE
COMMEMORATED COMMEMORATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AFRICAN
AMERICANS THIS TO FOLLOW AND
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
TO AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN WHO
HAVE DONE JUST THAT.
ELLA BAKER WAS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTIVIST WHO IS KNOWN FOR
SHINING A LIGHT ON SEXISM THAT
EXISTED WITHIN THE CIVIL CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
TODAY ELLA BAKER THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS WORKS
NATIONWIDE TO RE DIRECT
RESOURCES AWAY FROM PRISONS AND
PUNISHMENT AND TOWARDS
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP
COMMUNITIES GROW.
AT A HEALTHY AND STRONG MANNER.
DOROTHY HEIGHT WORKED AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS AND WOMEN'S ACTIVIST SHE
FOCUSED ON ISSUES AFFECTING
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN INCLUDING
UNEMPLOYMENT.
ILLITERACY AND VOTER AWARENESS
THROUGH CITIZEN EDUCATION
WORKSHOPS.
SHE WOULD GO ON LATER TO BE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HEAD START
PROGRAM IN ALABAMA VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR CENTER FOR
NONVIOLENT SOCIAL CHANGE IN
ATLANTA.
AND THE DIRECTOR OF STUDENT
ACTIVITIES AT CORNELL.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR SHE
RECEIVED THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL
OF FREEDOM AND TEN YEARS LATER
SHE RECEIVED THE CONGRESSIONAL
GOLD MEDAL.
AS WE CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH BUT A SUPPLY THE BRAVERY
AND STRENGTH OF THESE
TRAILBLAZING WOMEN AND SO MANY
OTHERS AND A KNOWLEDGE HOW MUCH
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE.
SO THAT WE CONTINUE TO OPEN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA.
CENTER DRAWS A GOOD AFTERNOON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
IT'S MY HONOR TO RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. C. R..
TWELVE YES BLACK HISTORY MONTH
IS IMPORTANT TO CELEBRATE AND
REFLECT ON THE TALENTS AND THE
ACHIEVEMENTS.
BUT TO ME MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
STRUGGLES OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
GENERATIONS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE MADE CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STATE AND OUR
ENTIRE NATION.
THERE ARE TWO THAT STAND OUT FOR
ME.
THE GREATER GOOD THURGOOD
MARSHALL'S LEGAL WORK.
THE BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF
EDUCATION CASE LAID THE
FOUNDATION FOR COUNTLESS OF
LEGAL ADVANCEMENTS THAT WOULD
OCCUR FOR DECADES AND DECADES
SINCE.
PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IN
CALIFORNIA TRIED TO UNDO.
THE RIGHT OF ALL CHILDREN. TWO
OF GOOD AND EVIL EDUCATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE VITAL WORK BY
DR KING AND HIS COMMITMENT. TO
THE STRUGGLES OF NONVIOLENCE.
IT WASN'T EARNS ONLY HIS FIGHT
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IT WAS HIS
CONTRIBUTION TO SAY WE CAN WIN
OUR STRUGGLES IN A NON VIOLENT
WAY.
THAT INSPIRED MANY FUTURE
POLITICAL ACTIVISTS INCLUDING
MYSELF AND AMONG THOSE THAT
DOCTOR KING ESPECIALLY
INFLUENCED WITH A YOUNG SAYS OUR
JOB IS.
ALONE THE SS I CHAVEZ WHO DIDN'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES WHO SAW ALL
ODDS AGAINST HIM.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COUNTRY HERE WAS DOCTOR KING
FIGHTING THROUGH NONVIOLENCE FOR
THE RIGHTS OF ALL PEOPLE CAUGHT
IS TO BE COURAGEOUS IN SPITE OF
BEING HATED.
AND FEARED.
THESE ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF
THE GREAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHOSE LIFE WORKS HAVE HAD SUCH A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE LATINO
COMMUNITY WE AS A COMMUNITY ARE
SO GRATEFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP
INSPIRATION AND SUPPORT.
OF ALL ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN
SISTERS AND BROTHERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
EXTEND OUR THANKS TO THE BLACK
CAUCUS FOR ITS LEADERSHIP AND
YOU WORK ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS RETURN
THE FORMER TO SENATOR MOORE Là
COULD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THE
LAST WEEK WE HAD A RESOLUTION
THAT WAS ON THE AGENDA. TO
CELEBRATE THE SESQUI CENTENNIAL.
OF THE FIRST FLOOR SESSION IN
THIS CAPITAL IT'S BEEN PUT ON AN
ACTIVE BUT I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
FOR DOING SOMETHING WITH THE
THEME OBSESSED WITH CENTENNIAL
AND WITH THAT THEME I'D LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT.
IN THIS MONTH IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS
AGO.
CONGRESS PROPOSED WHAT WOULD
BECOME THE FIFTEENTH AMENDMENT.
TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION UNDER THE
PRESIDENCY OF ULYSSES S. GRANT.
THE FIFTEENTH AMENDMENT
PROHIBITED THE DENIAL OF A
CITIZEN TO VOTE BASED ON RACE
COLOR OR PREVIOUS CONDITION OF
SERVITUDE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE ON IT SEE OUR TWELVE
THANK YOU SIR.
CENTER WIENER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY IS CHAIR
OF THE LGBT CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. YEAR.
TWELVE A BLACK HISTORY MONTH
SERVES AS AN IMPORTANT TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE --
THE EXPANSIVE HISTORY OF BLACK
PEOPLE NOT TO US IN THIS NATION
BUT AROUND THE WORLD --
I WANT TO TAKE THIS TIME TO
HIGHLIGHT ON SOME OF THE OFF
OFTEN FORGOTTEN CONTRIBUTIONS --
THE BLACK LGBT PEOPLE THIS
NATION IN THIS WORLD --
FOR EXAMPLE THE STORY OF JAMES
BALDWIN ROAD NOVELS AND PLAYS
THAT CENTERED --
THE STRUGGLE OF INTEGRATION AND
ACCEPTANCE WITHIN A COUNTRY
OTHER THAN I'D BOTH OF HIS
IDENTITIES.
THE STORY OF MARSHA P. JOHNSON.
WHO IS CREDITED WITH THROWING
THE IRST BRICK DURING THE
STONEWALL RIOTS?
STUDENTS AS FUEL RYAN XCELERATED
THE CONVERSATION PERMANENTLY
AROUND LGBT RIGHTS.
THE STORY OF AUDREY LORD PROUD --
FEMINISTS TO PUSHED THE WORLD TO
UNDERSTAND THE INTERSECTION OF
IDENTITY AND ISSUES SURROUNDING
CIVIL RIGHTS FEMINISM AND
OPPRESSION --
LANGSTON HUGHES WHO HELPED LEAD
THE HARLEM RENAISSANCE AND PUSH
YOUNG BLACK RIGHT WRITERS NOT TO
SHY AWAY FROM EXPRESSING THEIR
RACE IN THEIR WORK.
WE'RE LEVERING.
BULLARD* --
BLACK TRANS WOMAN WHO HAS
BROUGHT HER EXPERIENCE TO THE
BIG SCREEN AND HAS SERVED AS AN
INCREDIBLY VISIBLE ROLE MODEL --
TO SO MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND HAS HELPED GIVE
TRANS PEOPLE A NEW LEVEL OF
VISIBILITY AND REPRESENTATION.
ARE COLLEAGUES WILL BE FRANK
THAT A BLACK PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE BIAS DISCRIMINATION
PREJUDICE AND VIOLENCE AT ALL
LEVELS OF SOCIETY.
AND THE SITUATION IS EVEN MORE
SEVERE OFFER LGBT BLACK PEOPLE
WHO LIVE AT THE INTERSECTION OF
RACISM.
HOMOPHOBIA AND TRANSPHOBIA --
A KNOWLEDGE JIANG THE HISTORIC
EXPERIENCES OF BLACK CULTURE BE
TWO PEOPLE IT'S JUST ONE OF THE
MANY WAYS.
THAT WE CAN STRIVE TO RIGHT THE
WRONGS --
THE OUR COMMUNITY STILL
EXPERIENCE.
BOB FOR THIS REASON ON MANY
OTHERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
GIVEN MUCH SOONER WIENER.
MEMBERS RETURNED FROM THE FLOOR
OVER TO CENTER HUESO.
THANK YOU AND PRESIDENT I RISE
ALSO IN SUPPORT AND JUST TO TO
MAKE A MENTION.
OF AYE.
THERE JUST SO MUCH SO MANY JOBS.
EXAMPLES OF AMAZING PEOPLE.
THAT OUR HAVE SERVED OUR COUNTRY
FROM THE AMERICAN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT SOME THAT
ARE ARE ARE LESS REMEMBERED.
THAT -- ARE
A TESTAMENT.
TO THIS COMMUNITY THAT HAS SHOWN
JUST.
AMAZING RESILIENCE.
IN THE FACE OF SO MUCH
OPPRESSION.
YOU KNOW WHAT WITHOUT THERE
THERE'S A SAYING THAT WE YOU
CAN'T KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO
YOU CAN KNOW WHO YOU ARE WITHOUT
KNOWING.
WHERE YOU CAME FROM?
THEN I I FEEL TODAY WHEN WERE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT.
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT AND AND WHERE
WEALTHIEST COUNTRY CONCENTRATOR
OUR COMMUNITY WE OFTEN.
FAIL TO LOOK AT HISTORY.
AND NOW HISTORY HAS BROUGHT US
TO WHERE WE ARE.
AND AND I SEE SO MANY EXAMPLES
IN HISTORY OF THIS.
AMAZING PEOPLE THAT DESPITE.
BEING BROUGHT HERE AGAINST THEIR
WILL TO AMERICA DESPITE.
BEING ENSLAVED DESPITE BEING --
PRESSED IN EVERY WAY.
OF A COMMUNITY THAT HAS DONE
MORE FOR THIS COUNTRY IN THE
AREAS OF OF CULTURE.
MUSIC WHEN YOU THINK OF JAZZ.
AND AND YOU AND YOU THINK OF OF
OF OF ALL THE MUSICAL STYLES
THAT WE HAVE AND WE HAVE JUST.
AMAZING ARTISTS THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CREATION OF
OUR OF OUR MUSIC OF OUR FOOD.
OF OF ARCHITECTURE.
THERE ARE SO MANY INFLUENCES
THAT WE HAVE.
BY BY A COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE THAT.
MADE THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS WHILE
BEING OPPRESSED.
THEIR STORES SO MANY STORIES OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE SO COURAGEOUS
THAT HAVE BEEN FORGOTTEN.
LIKE ONE OF GEORGE WASHINGTON'S
SLAVES.
OWN A JUDGE THAT IT'S AT THE AGE
OF NINETEEN WHILE SERVING HIM.
IN IN IN PHILADELPHIA HAD THE
COURAGE TO RUN AWAY AND BECOME A
FREE WOMAN.
SHE RAN AWAY SHE BASICALLY
DEFIED THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN
THE LAND.
I CAN I JUST I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT WAS TO BE --
NOW AND TO BE CONTEMPLATING.
RUNNING AWAY FROM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AT THE TIME.
AND IT JUST A OR THE THE LAST
SLAVES TO EVER.
BE TRAFFICKED INTO THE US.
ILLEGALLY.
THAT WAS A SHIPMENT THE CAVEMAN
THE LAST SHIPMENT THAT WAS
ACTUALLY INTERCEPTED AND THEY
WERE BROUGHT INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY AFTER.
OUR THE SLAVE TRADE HAD BEEN.
MADE ILLEGAL.
AND HOW.
THESE INDIVIDUALS PETITION TO BE
RETURNED TO AFRICA AND NEVER
WERE RETURNED [inaudible]
AND THESE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THEY REFUSED. TO GIVE UP THEIR
CULTURE THEY ESTABLISHED.
I TOWN IN ALABAMA CALLED AFRICA
TOWN WITH THE PURPOSE OF OF
LIVING THEIR LIVES.
AS IF THEY WERE STILL LIVING IN
AFRICA.
THAT THAT COURAGE THAT DEFIANCE
AND THAT.
WILLINGNESS TO DEFY AN ENTIRE
COUNTRY. TO PRESERVE PRESERVE
YOUR CULTURE.
IS I THINK WHAT AMERICA.
REALLY IS ABOUT AND WHAT AMERICA
SHOULD BE ABOUT.
ABOUT.
LIVING YOUR LIFE ACCORDING TO
YOUR BELIEFS AND PRINCIPLES AND
AND PRESERVING YOUR CULTURAL
HERITAGE.
AND PRESERVING YOUR HISTORY.
EVERY DAY WE'RE MAKING NEW
GAINES AT LEARNING MORE AND MORE
ABOUT HISTORY AND I I JUST
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE. TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT WHO THEY ARE WHERE THEY
COME FROM AND AND WHAT.
THEIR PARENTS SAID FOUR BEARS
ALL THE SACRIFICES THEY MADE TO
BRING US WHERE WE ARE NOW.
I THINK.
IT IT IT IS A A SOURCE OF
INSPIRATION AND GIVE US STRENGTH.
TO PURSUE A BETTER FUTURE FOR
OURSELVES OUR FAMILIES SO I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE. FOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
AND FOR KEEPING.
THE HISTORY ALIVE IN OUR STATE
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE WHO WHERE WE'VE BEEN
AND WHO WE ARE.
WITH THE HOPES THAT WE WILL GO
TO A BETTER PLACE IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA TAKE THE
FOLLOWING SENATORS IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER.
SENATOR GROW.
SENATOR ARCHULETA CONSIDER
MITCHELL.
CENTER GROVE THE FORESHORES GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AS THE FIRST FEMALE
VETERAN TO EVER SERVE IN THIS
BUILDING I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
VETERAN --
THAT IS THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
INDIVIDUAL THAT SERVED IN WORLD
WAR.
TWO AND IT WAS IMPORTANT TO SAY
THIS BECAUSE I I THINK VETERANS
SHOULD BE HONORED --
EXTREMELY --
WELL --
EDWARD ALLEN A CARTER US
SERGEANT FIRST CLASS IN WORLD
WAR TWO AND BACK IN WORLD WAR
TWO THEY SEPARATED THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN TROOPS FROM THE
CAUCASIAN TROOPS.
AND HE WAS ON AFTER HE SERVED IN
SHANGHAI IN IN THE EUROPEAN
THEATER TO JOIN THE SPANISH
LOYALIST IN ORDER TO STOP.
OF FRANCO'S REGIME HE ACTUALLY
GOT STATIONED IN WORLD WAR TWO
ERA IN GERMANY.
HE HAD A BRIGADE OR EXCUSE ME A
SMALL GROUP OF THREE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS AND NOT WANTING ON
PATROL THEIR TANK HAD TAKEN
BAZOOKA FIRE.
IN DURING THAT BAZOOKA FIRED
ENABLED THERE TO GET STOPPED OR
DISABLED THEIR TANK AND THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO CONTINUE.
WHEN THEY GOT OUT OF THE TANK TO
START TO MOVE FORWARD THEY
REALIZE THEY WERE UNDER HEAVY
FIRE AND AFTER HIDING BEHIND A
WALL FOR A LONG TIME?
HE REALIZED THAT THE THREE
PEOPLE HIS COMRADES THAT WERE
WITH HIM WE'RE GOING TO BE
THEY'LL DIE IF HE DOESN'T DO
SOMETHING SO THIS BRAVE MAN TOOK
AND RAN OVER IF IT RAN A CROSS
AN OPEN FIELD --
TAKING HEAVY GUNFIRE TO DRAW
FIRE AWAY FROM THE GERMANS THAT
WERE SHOOTING AT THE AT THE AT
IS TEAM.
AND WHEN HE WAS RUNNING ACROSS
THAT FIELD HE SHE WAS SHOT HE
HIT THE GROUND THEY TOOK OUT
PART OF HIS THIGH HE WAS SHOT
AGAIN IN THE SHOULDER HE SHOT
AGAIN.
IN THE SIDE OF HIS NECK AND
EVERY TIME HE CONTINUE TO GET UP
AND RAN TOWARDS THAT --
HEAVY MACHINE GUN FIRE UNTIL HE
WAS ABLE TO THROW A GRENADE INTO
THAT.
OPPOSITION TO STOP THAT --
SHOOTING FROM TAKING PLACE ON
HIS MEN THAT HE HAD LEFT BEHIND
THAT WALL THAT HE WANTED TO
PROTECT. ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
I WANT TO BRING IT TODAY IS IS
THAT DURING THAT IS I BELIEVE
THAT ALL VETERANS ARE GREEN.
I THINK IN THE MILITARY DOESN'T
MATTER WHO YOU'RE IN THIS IN THE
FOXHOLE WITH YOUR GREEN IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHEN YOU'RE IN A
POSITION LIKE THAT IT DOESN'T
MATTER RACE GOES COMPLETELY OUT
THE WINDOW.
YOU'RE ALL THEIR FOR AMERICANS.
AND BECAUSE WHAT BOTHERS ME
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR STORY IS A
BACK THEN HE WASN'T EVEN THOUGH
HE MET ALL THE CRITERIA FOR THE
MEDAL OF HONOR THE HIGHEST AWARD
THAT YOU CAN RECEIVE IN MILITARY.
AND IN THE GOVERNMENT THE
HIGHEST MILITARY AWARD IS A
MEDAL OF HONOR.
IN BACK THEN THEY DIDN'T ALLOW
AFRICAN AMERICANS TO HAVE THE
MEDAL OF HONOR SO HE WAS PUT IN
FOR A DISTINGUISHED PROCESS
WHICH THEY DID GIVE HIM.
BUT IT WASN'T TOO MANY MANY
YEARS LATER THAT HE WAS ACTUALLY --
GIVEN AFTER HIS DEATH THE MEDAL
OF HONOR IT WAS PRESENTED BY
PRESIDENT CLINTON TO HIS SON.
WHO GRACIOUSLY RECEIVE THAT
PROCEDURE SO WARD FOR HIS
SERVICE IN WORLD WAR --
TWO AND SO I JUST WANT TO BRING
UP A MILITARY VETERAN TODAY AND
THANK YOU GUYS OFFER HONORING A
BLACK HISTORY MONTH AND I WOULD
VOTE I ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR.
CENTER ARCHULETA FLOOR SHORES IN
MARIN GO TO SENATOR STONE.
MISTER PRESIDENT I I SPEAK ON A
MORE PERSONAL NOTE.
AS I HAD MENTIONED ONE TIME
BEFORE I WAS A PARATROOPER WITH
THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE.
IN MY FIRST TIME IN COMBAT TO MY
LEFT AND TO MY RIGHT.
FELLOW PARATROOPERS AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
TOGETHER.
WE COMPLETED WHAT WE HAD TO DO.
BUT OVER THE YEARS.
BEEN STATIONED AT FORT BRAGG
NORTH CAROLINA BACK IN THE
SIXTIES.
FROM LOS ANGELES. TO WALK DOWN
THE STREET TO NORTH CAROLINA Và
FAYETTEVILLE NC THE SIGN.
BLACKS OR WHITES WATER FOUNTAINS
AND SHOWN I'D NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE IN MY LIFE.
AND HERE I AM KID FROM LOS
ANGELES SURROUND WITH MY FRIENDS.
AND I SAID HEY JOHNSON WHAT IS
THAT.
HE SAID BOB YOU DON'T KNOW THIS
IS NOT LOS ANGELES THIS IS NOT
THIS IS THE SOUTH.
I WALKED IT EXPERIENCE THAT.
ORDER THE MOVIES WALKING DOWN
THE STREET.
IS THAT BOB WE GOT A SEPARATE
RIGHT HERE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GO UPSTAIRS I'M GONNA HAVE TO GO
DOWNSTAIRS BUT WE CAN'T BE
TOGETHER DOES MOVIE HOUSE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
HERO CAT MY FELLOW PARATROOPERS
AT FORT BRAGG WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO DRINK TOGETHER.
JUMP BUT AIRPLANES TOGETHER AND
EVENTUALLY GO OFF TO COMBAT
TOGETHER BUT WE COULDN'T EAT
TOGETHER AT THAT RESTAURANT.
THIS WAS IN. NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX IMAGINE HOW I'VE SEEN
THE WORLD COME BACKGROUND SO
EQUALITY FINALLY IS TAKING HOLD.
WE'VE HAD A PRESIDENT WE'RE
ABOUT TO HAVE GOD WILLING MAYBE
ANOTHER.
ONE BUT I AM SO PROUD OF WHAT
YOU'VE DONE TODAY CENTER
BRADFORD TO STAND UP AND CENTER
HOLLY MITCHELL THE STAND UP AS
WELL.
BRING US TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE GEN UNDER ONE GOD AND WE
ARE GOT CHILDREN.
SO I'D LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM WHO HAVE DONE SO WELL.
NOT AT WEST NOT JUST WEST POINT
BUT ACROSS THE LEADERSHIP.
ACROSS.
THE NAVY THE ARMY THE AIR FORCE
MARINE CORPS ACROSS.
THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF SERVICE.
THEY ARE MAKING THIS PROUD MEN
AND WOMEN THANK YOU AND GOD
BLESS YOU ALL THANK YOU AND I
ALSO AGREE THAT WE SHOULD HONOR
THE MALL TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS RETURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR STONE
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BEAUTIFUL RESOLUTION.
FORD I'M I'M NOT STANDING
REPRESENTING ANY PARTICULAR
CAUCUS UNDERSTANDING IS A PROUD
AMERICAN RESPECTFUL.
OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN HERITAGE
AND HISTORY THAT WE HAVE --
SEE AND AND THE UNITED STATES
AND I WANT TO BE A PARTICULAR
ATTENTION --
TO TWENTY MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS
THAT HAVE MADE --
IN ADVANCES IN MEDICINE.
OFTEN AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
I'M JUST I'M NOT GONNA MENTION
ALL IN JUST A FEW OF THEM I
THINK THAT ARE HIGHLY NOTABLE
ALEXANDER AUGUSTA MD THE FIRST.
BLACK PHYSICIAN APPOINTED TO BE
THE DIRECTOR OF A US HOSPITAL --
PATRICIA BATH M. D. THE FIRST
BLACK FEMALE PHYSICIAN AWARDED A
PATENT FOR A MEDICAL
INTERVENTION.
WHICH MANY OF OUR RELATIVES HAVE
ENJOYED BECAUSE SHE INVENTED THE
LASER FAKE CO.
WHICH IS A DEVICE USED TO TREAT
CATARACTS A REVOLUTIONARY
TREATMENT THAT WOULD NOT HAVE --
COME TO FRUITION WITHOUT HER
INNOVATION AND SHE IS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
MEDICAL PRACTITIONER TO RECEIVE
A PATENT IN THE UNITED STATES.
LONG EIGHT BREASTS BRISTOW CAM
D. THE FIRST BLACK POSITION LIKE
COULD BE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
LX THAT KENNEDY MD THE FIRST
BLACK FEMALE NEUROSURGEON.
AND OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW --
DR BEN CARSON.
WHO IS THE FIRST NEUROSURGEON
[inaudible] TO BASICALLY BREAK
APART CONJOINED TWINS
SUCCESSFULLY --
ALLOWING FOR LIFE --
FOR FOR BOTH OF THESE --
PATIENTS.
OUR REBEKAH CRUMPLER AND BE THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN AWARDED A
MEDICAL DEGREE FROM A U. S.
COLLEGE.
WAS OF COURSE IS BACK IN THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS BUT SET THE
PRESIDENT. FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR INNER
KNOWLEDGE AND DESIRE TO HELP AND
SERVE.
SICK PEOPLE.
N. CHARLES DREW MD THE FIRST TO
USE BLOOD PLASMA AND STORE BLOOD
FOR TRANSFUSIONS.
WHICH IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
SAVING MILLIONS OF LIVES IN THE
UNITED STATES [inaudible]
SO.
AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE OFFER OF
BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
AND I I'VE I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE WONDERFUL COMMENTS FROM
ALL -- MY
COLLEAGUES MENTIONING THE
WONDERFUL CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE MADE IN
THE PAST.
AND WE KNOW THE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE MADE IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
CENTER MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I APPRECIATE YOU OUT
LIKE TO THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE LEADERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR BRADFORD.
OF VICE CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND DRIVING ONE'S
ATTENTION TO THE GIFT HE'S
AFFORDED US ALL --
I THINK PERHAPS AS WE ALL --
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SIXTEEN
SIXTEEN MONTH TWENTY NINETEEN
LACKEY THREE CALENDAR WE WILL
READ ABOUT THE HISTORY OF SOME
MORE IMPORTANT AFRICAN AMERICANS --
IN OUR NATION.
ARE ASKED OFF TO A SCHOOL IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND SO WE CAN
SPREAD THE LOVE.
ALL AND KNOWLEDGE.
I'D LIKE TO THINK OF ALL OF US
FOR COLLECTIVELY TALKING ABOUT
THE IMPORTANT STRIDES AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO THIS
COUNTRY MY FATHER SERVED IN THE
SEGREGATED --
WW TWO WAS HE WOULD SAY AND
TALKED ABOUT HE EXPERIENCE
ANYTHING BUT EQUITY --
IN THAT BLACK SOLDIERS WERE
GIVEN AMMUNITION WHEN THEY WERE --
TO STAND GUARD AT NIGHT AND SO
ON THAT'S THE DAUGHTER OF A MAN
WHO SERVED IN IN THE GREAT WAR --
I CAN CERTAINLY ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT HE DIDN'T HE FELT
EVERYTHING.
INCLUDING SEPARATE AND UNEQUAL.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE
TALK ABOUT BLACK HISTORY MONTH
THAT WE TALK ABOUT ABOUT AND IT
NOW IS THE REALITIES OF BLACK
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE EVERY DAY IN
THIS GREAT STATE OF OURS IN THIS
COUNTRY [inaudible]
BLACK FACE [inaudible]
IMPLICIT BIAS.
OVER INCARCERATION.
BLACK INFANT MORTALITY.
BLACK MATERNAL MORBIDITY.
TAKING THE KNEE IN PROTEST.
EDUCATIONAL IN EQUITY.
HEY IN EQUITY.
POLICE EXCESSIVE FORCE.
BLACK LIVES MATTER [inaudible]
VOTER SUPPRESSION.
HAVING YOUR NATURAL HAIR CUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF A HIGH SCHOOL
WRESTLING MATCH.
BEAN UNCLE NEAREST NEAREST GREEN
THE MAN WHO TAUGHT JACK DANIELS.
HOW TO BE A MASTER DISTILLER?
AND HAVING THAT REALITY JUST
COME TO THE FOREFRONT TODAY.
THIS IN RECENT HISTORY YOU
HUNDREDS OF YEARS LATER.
WE ALL KNOW JACK DANIELS.
NOBODY KNOWS NEAR SCREEN.
AND WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE CONTRIBUTIONS AFTER
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
HISTORICALLY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE TALK ABOUT NICK
KNOWLEDGE CONTRIBUTIONS AFRICAN
AMERICANS MAKE.
EACH AND EVERY DAY. TWO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF ALL AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIANS A PARTICULAR.
I THINK IT'S TRAGIC THAT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT WE'RE EVEN
HAVING A DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER
BLACKFACE IS OFFENSIVE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTION IN YOUR
MIND LET ME SELL IT FOR YOU
TODAY.
EDS.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT BLACK
HISTORY THESE THE TIME WE SPENT
ON THE FLOOR TO DO THESE
COMMEMORATIONS I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
GIVES US A MOMENT. TO PAUSE IN
TIME.
AND PERHAPS THINK ABOUT OUR OWN
KNOWLEDGE.
LACK THEREOF.
BIASES.
AND PERHAPS MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
OUR SALES IN OUR CONSTITUENTS.
THAT WE WILL WORK VERY HARD TO
BE BETTER AND DO BETTER.
AS WE PRIORITIZE CRITICAL PUBLIC
POLICY ISSUES THAT IMPACT ALL
CALIFORNIANS BLACK IN OTHERWISE.
AS MY COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT
BEING FROM CALIFORNIA NOT BEING
EXPOSED TO SOME OF THE
SEGREGATION OBVIOUS SIGNS OF THE
SOUTH.
I WANT TO BRING EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION TO THE DISPLAY THAT
THE BLACK CAUCUS IS MADE
AVAILABLE OUTSIDE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
IF THE DISPLAY IS ENTITLED
CALIFORNIA BOUND SLAVERY ON THE
NEW FRONTIER FROM.
EIGHTEEN FORTY TO EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE AS AN EXHIBIT THAT WAS
CURATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MUSEUM IN
EXPOSITION PARK IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT GIVES A VERY PAINFUL LOOK
AT CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WITH
REGARD TO THE SLAVE TRADE
ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE --
THAT REVERSED ITSELF ON TWO
OCCASIONS IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR
NOT WE WERE GOING TO ALLOW SLAVE
OWNERS FROM THE SOUTH MAINTAINED
THEIR OWNERSHIP OF HUMAN BEANS
ONCE THEY CAME ACROSS INTO
CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING THE GOLD RUSH.
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA
POLICY MAKERS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE BLOOD IS ON UR HANDS.
TO THAT WE TO HAVE A
QUESTIONABLE HISTORY IN TERMS OF
THE LAND OF THE FREE.
FLOW AGAIN I WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DISPLAY AND LEARN SOME THINGS
LIKE IDEA IT WILL ONLY BE ON
DISPLAY OUT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE UNTIL FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
BLACK FACE IMPLICIT BIAS OVER
INCARCERATION.
POLICE EXCESSIVE FORCE
[inaudible]
PAY EQUITY [inaudible]
VOTER SUPPRESSION.
ALL ISSUES THAT A COMMUNITY
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPERIENCES
EACH AND EVERY DAY COMPARED TO
OUR COLLEAGUES.
IN THIS VERY CHAMBERS. FOR THOSE
REASONS AND MANY MORE I WILL
PROBABLY CAST MY VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF S. C. R..
TWELVE AS A SYMBOL OF MY OWN
PERSONAL COMMITMENT AS A BLACK
WOMAN IN AMERICA AS A STATE
SENATOR IN THIS HOUSE TO
CONTINUE TO DO ALL I CAN. TO
CREATE A TRUE SENSE OF EQUITY
AND FAIRNESS FOR ALL.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER
MITCHELL FOR THOSE ELOQUENT
WORDS WITH ACTIVATED TURN IT
OVER TO SENATOR BRADFORD PENNY
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
CENTER BRADFORD CAN YOU PLEASE
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE LENT THEIR
VOICE ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION TODAY.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK AND
HIGHLIGHT MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
HOLLY MITCHELL FOR HER.
COURAGE AND ABILITY TO SPEAK
TRUTH TO POWER LIKE NO ONE ELSE
AND THE FANTASTIC JOB SHE'S
DOING AS THE FIRST FEMALE.
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN BUDGET YEAR
AND THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA SO
AS YOU CAN SEE WE'RE STILL
MAKING HISTORY TODAY.
AND WE'VE ALL MADE TREMENDOUS
SACRIFICES TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT
REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE COME FROM
BUT I THINK WE ALL HAVE TO AGREE
THERE'S NOT BEEN A GREATER
SACRIFICE OF THE ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED YEARS OF AND SLAVERY
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS.
EXPERIENCE IN THIS COUNTRY TO
MAKE AMERICA GREAT IT IS ALREADY
GREAT BUT WE ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE.
IN THIS NATION WHO HAVE NEVER
RECEIVED LET ME BE CLEAR WE'RE
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER
RECEIVED REPARATIONS FOR THE
SERVICE THAT WE'VE MADE TO THIS
COUNTRY AMERICA THAT WE
EXPERIENCE THE DAY THAT WE KNOW
THE DAY THAT WE ALL LOVE THE DAY.
WOULD OT BE POSSIBLE IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE CUT CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AMERICANS OF AFRICAN DESCENT.
ON THAT NOTE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO NOT ONLY
HONOR THIS MONTH.
BUT HONOR THE CONTRIBUTIONS ON A
DAILY BASIS BECAUSE IF YOU
REALLY GIVE THOUGHT TO IT IT
IMPACTS OUR LIVES IN EACH AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO ON A DAILY
BASIS YOU CANNOT EXPERIENCE LIFE
IN THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT BEING
IMPACTED BY SOMETHING.
OR CONTRIBUTION THAT A PERSON OF
COLOR HAS MADE TO THIS NATION SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. C. R..
TWELVE MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
I WERE JUST.
BY BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
HI.
GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HI.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WISH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED.
I AM RAIL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
BY WIECKOWSKI.
AYE WIENER.
BY WILK.
BY.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOT GONNA E
TURNING TO THE PRO TEM'S DESK
WITH SENATOR MITCHELL.
WITH SAM'S.
SPECIAL INTRODUCTIONS.
CENTER BRADFORD WILL KICK US OFF
WISIN SPECIAL INTRODUCTION
CENTER BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS%
YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IN
CONJUCTION WITH BLACK HISTORY
MONTH.
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE ARE HONORING.
CAN UNSUNG HEROES FROM OUR
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS TODAY.
A UNSUNG HEROES ONE WHO DOES
GREAT DEEDS BUT RECEIVED LITTLE
OR NO RECOGNITION FOR THEM.
THAT WILL CHANGE TODAY.
IT IS MY HONOR TO GIVE
RECOGNITION TO UNSUNG HERO OF
THE THIRTY FIFTH SENATE DISTRICT
WHICH I REPRESENT.
THAT IN THE PERSON OF MISS OZZY
BE GONE JACK.
OF THE TENDER AGE OF NINETY
THREE MS CONCEPT WAS BORN IN
ARKANSAS.
AND WAS RAISED AND MONAURAL%
LOUISIANA AND AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY SHE WAS SENT WEST BY HER
FATHER TO ACQUIRE PROPERTY
BECAUSE HER FATHER HAD PAID OFF
PROPERTY THAT HE IT.
PURCHASED IN LUCIANA AN ACTIVE --
SATISFYING THE D. THEY WOULDN'T
GIVE HIM HIS DUE TO THE PROPERTY.
ANY DECIDED I WOULD NO LONGER
LIVE IN THE STATE THAT I PAID
OFF SO SHE WENT WEST TO LOS
ANGELES.
MISS CONTACT.
HEY WHAT'S NATIVE OF OVER
SEVENTY THREE YEARS OF CERTAIN
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CAPACITIES
FROM.
COMMISSIONER TO CHEER OF THE LOS
ANGELES HOUSING AUTHORITY.
HER LEADERSHIP UNITED DISPIRITED
AT UPWARD MOMENT MOBILITY OF
HOUSING FOR URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
THE ENTIRE STAFF OF THE LA CITY
HOUSING AUTHORITY.
RESIDENTS OF THE TWENTY ONE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN THE CITY
OF LA ONE WHICH BEARS HER NAME
AND THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
SHE WAS THE BED ROCK IN BLUE OF
UNIFYING THE COMMUNITY A WHAT'S
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AFTER
THE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE CIVIL
UNREST.
MISS CONTACT AS WELL KNOWN AS A
GRASSROOTS REPRESENTATIVE WHO
FOUGHT FOR RESPECT RIGHTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE RESIDENTS
OF THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
SOMETIMES CALLED THE PROJECTS.
AND THOSE INTRODUCED
TRANSITIONAL AND GROWTH ORIENTED
STAGES OF THEIR LIVES.
AMONG HER MANY OUTSTANDING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS STATED.
HE'S ALSO.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TEAM.
AMATO THAT IS EMBLAZONED ON
EVERY LA POLICE CAR IN THE CITY
OF LA TO PROTECT AND TO SERVER.
AND MANY TIMES THEY FEEL
CHARLOTTE THAT.
SHE'S A PROUD MOTHER OF THREE
DAUGHTERS TWO OF WHICH ARE WITH
THIRTY DAY BERNADETTE AND
BARBARA. TWO STEP DAUGHTERS.
AND TWO STEP SON SHE IS ALSO THE
GRANDMOTHER SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND TEN GRAND
CHILDREN AND SHE'S ALSO.
A JOINED TODAY BY HER GOOD
FRIEND COUNTS --
CALUMET SO.
MISS GUNS AS HAD A CONTACT HAS
DEDICATED HER LIFE TO THE PEOPLE
WHAT'S AND PRIDE OURSELVES ON
BEING A CALIFORNIA.
SHE LOVES THE STATE WHERE YOU
LIVE HAS NO BEARING ON WHO YOU
ARE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T VISITED MISS
GHANA SECOND WHAT'S THE ISSUE
SAID YOU YOU PROBABLY HAVEN'T
BEEN INVITED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING OZZY
BE GONE ZACH A WOMAN OF
EXEMPLARY COURAGE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT A PUBLIC SERVANTS SHOULD BE.
THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELCOME INCLUDING KEY PEELE
CREDIBLE ACCOMPLISHMENT
.
AT THIS TIME I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE SIR MITCHELL TO RECOGNIZE
HER UNSUNG HERO OF THE THIRTY OF
SENATE DISTRICT.
CENTER MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT --
SENATOR BRADFORD AND COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND PATIENCE
WE ALL POSSESS THE CAPACITY TO
BE A HERO.
A HERO IS SOMEONE WHO GOES OUT
OF HER WAY TO BE A PART OF
SOMETHING BIGGER THAN HERSELF.
HE UNSELFISHLY CHOOSES TO SERVE
AND POUR INTO HER COMMUNITY HE
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY ACTION IS
INTENTIONALLY CONDUCTED WITH
LOVE.
I AM PROUD TO DAY TO JOIN WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
RECOGNIZE THE UNSUNG HERO FOR
THE THIRTIETH SENATE DISTRICT.
MS JEWELL FE ES WILLIAM.
YOU ALL GREW UP ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN CIVIC WE ENGAGE IN
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY UNTIL
SHE MOVED TO LA TO ATTEND UCLA
[inaudible]
IN.
SEVENTY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SHE
HER ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT LED
HER TO OPEN AN OPERATE HER OWN.
WOMEN'S CLOTHING BOUTIQUE UNTIL
SHE RETURNED TO UCLA TO GRADUATE
WITH HER DEGREE.
WAS BIG DREAMS AND A STRONG WILL
YOU'LL PURCHASE THE PIECE OF
PROPERTY A SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD
BAR CALLED THE DIANA CLUB.
HE TRANSFORM THIS CLUB INTO WHAT
IS NOW INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AS JULES CATCH ONE
DISCO OR THE CATCH.
AS WE SAY IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND IT'S COME ALL THAT FOR OVER
FORTY TWO YEARS.
THE CATCH WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
BLACK DISCOS IN THE UNITED
STATES AND WAS THE LONGEST
RUNNING BLACK GAY DANCE CLUB IN
LA.
WITH PERFORMANCES FROM ARTISTS
LIKE LUTHER VANDROSS AND JANET
JACKSON WHITNEY HOUSTON.
MADONNA WAS A REGULAR THE DONNA
SUMMER.
THE CATS MOST IMPORTANTLY WAS A
SAFE HAVEN IN LOS ANGELES WHERE
BLACK PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT AGES
AND SEXUAL ORIENTATIONS.
COULD JOIN TOGETHER AND HAVE FUN
AND DANCE AND BE WHO THEY ARE.
YOU'LL SOON SOLVE THE IMPACT THE
HIV AIDS VIRUS WAS HAVING ON THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN ACROSS OUR COMMUNITY.
AND SHE SAW THE NEED FOR
HOLISTIC HEALTH CARE SERVICE IN
HER OWN COMMUNITY.
AND SHE DECIDED TO STUDY
TRADITIONAL CHINESE MEDICINE AND
OBTAIN A MASTER OF SCIENCE
DEGREE.
HE NOW SERVES THE PUBLIC AS A
LICENSED ACUPUNCTURISTS AND
HERBALISTS IN HER OWN CLINIC THE
VILLAGE HEALTH FOUNDATION.
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE JUL HAVE
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN DEVELOPING
NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
UNITY FELLOWSHIP CHURCH AIDS
PROJECT LOS ANGELES.
LADIES CONCERNED IMANI LEAD ALSO
FOOD BANK AND RULES HOUSE THE
FIRST RESIDENTIAL HOME IN THE
COUNTRY FOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN
LIVING WITH AIDS.
JUL HAS WORN MANY HATS BUT SHE
REMAINS CONSISTENT INTO THINGS.
HE'S DEDICATED TO EACH ENDEAVOR
AND SHE STRIVE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF THOSE
AROUND HER.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING YOU'LL SAY YES WILLIAM.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. THREE GIVE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA
.
WE'RE GOING THE TAKE A GROUP
SHOT WITH BOTH OF OUR ON A
REASON WE WELCOME ALL SENATORS
TO BE ABLE TO BE IN THE PICTURE
.
WE HAVE ONE MORE.
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH
THE HONOREES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD AND
SENATOR MITCHELL.
SENATORS AS YOU RETURNED YOUR
DESKS WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO
CONTINUE WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
SENATOR HELP.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY WE HAVE MEMBERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FAMILY CAREER AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS OF AMERICA VISIT IN THE
CAPITAL.
THE STUDENT LEADERS REPRESENT
THE NEARLY ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN AND ROLLED IN FAMILY AND
CONSUMER SCIENCES CLASSES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME THEM TO
THE STATE CAPITOL IN SO GREAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO HEAR THE
TRIBUTE IN THE CELEBRATION OF
BLACK HISTORY MONTH TODAVíA
PLEASE.
AND AND THAT'S GIVE THEM A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE WELCOME. TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA PROCEED.
WITH MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THOSE MESSAGES WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
ANY MEMBERS ENTER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS IN NOTICES
[inaudible]
SEE.
NINE MEMBERS WE'D LIKE TO
ADVANCE TO INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
THE BILL 235-236-2372
382-392-40240 ONE TO FORTY TWO
TO FORTY THREE BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO WORK.
BRIEFLY THE SENATE THIRD READING
IN THE DAILY FILE AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
SO MEMBERS WITH ACTIVATED TAKE
UP ITEM NUMBER TWO UNDER SENATE.
THIRD READING.
SENATOR PAN IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
MR SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TEN
BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO FRED
KOREMATSU DAY OF CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER PAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS SAW.
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AT RICE TO BRING BEFORE
YOU ACR TEN WHICH DESIGNATES
JANUARY THIRTIETH THIS FRED
KOREMATSU DAY OF CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS YEAR WE ARE ABLE TO HONOR
THE LEGACY OF FRED KOREMATSU ON
HIS HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY WHICH
FELL ON JANUARY THIRTIETH.
FRED KOREMATSU RESISTED AND
PERSISTED DURING A GREGIS
CHAPTER IN OUR HISTORY.
HE CHALLENGE THE GOVERNMENT'S
DECISION TO CAR ST JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO
AND PRODUCE CASE TO THE SUPREME
COURT.
FRED KOREMATSU CONTINUES
CONTINUED HIS EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT AMERICANS DO NOT FORGET THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM OUR OWN
HISTORY AS YOU TRAVEL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
SPEAKING AT VARIOUS COLLEGES LAW
SCHOOLS AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS HAVE FOUGHT FOR
CENTURIES DEFERRED DISSIPATE
FREELY AND THE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
LIFE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE REPAIR AFTER BARRIER TO PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
CHALLENGE UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAWS
SO WE CAN BENEFIT FROM YOUR
VICTORIES.
FRED KOREMATSU IS AN EXCELLENT
EXAMPLE OF THIS MAY ASK YOU JOIN
ME IN HONORING HIM BY VOTING AYE
ON THIS YOUR TEN THANK YOU.
MEMBERS TO A DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON ALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
XENON.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BELL [inaudible]
I GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
BY MERRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
BARBARA.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
OKAY.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATE MITCHELL US IMPORTANT
GUESTS ELECTED BETTER RECOGNIZE
I REALLY DO SOMEONE I THINK
EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW
[inaudible]
SO.
IF YOU'VE BEEN TO LA YOU ALL
HOPEFULLY HAVE BEEN TO THE
NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM YOU KNOW
IT SITUATED ON LAND THAT SERVED
AS THE AGRICULTURAL FAIR GROUND
FROM EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO UNTIL.
NINETEEN TEN AND IT WAS THE
NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM THAT
BECAME THE FIRST PUBLIC MUSEUM
IN LA IN.
NINETEEN THIRTEEN IT PROTECTS
OVER THIRTY FIVE MILLION
SPECIMENS DATING BACK FOUR AND A
HALF BILLION YEARS AND SERVES AS
A TREMENDOUS RESOURCE FOR
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS [inaudible]
NOT.
WELL THAT'S ALL IN ITSELF
LAUDABLE DOCTOR LORI BETTIS AND
VARGAS PRESIDENT DIRECTOR BUT
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT YOU REALLY
WANT TO KNOW DOCTOR MEDICINE
BARCA.
WE VOTED A COUPLE YEARS AGO TO
NAME A STATE DINOSAUR.
SENATOR BASS IS GONNA BUY ME A
CUP OF COFFEE BY GET HIS NAME
RIGHT.
WE VOTED TO DECLARE AUGUSTINE A
LOS FELIZ MORRISSEY.
BOB TO BUY MY OWN COPY.
HE LIVES AT THE NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM.
AND DOCTOR BENEFIT VARGA THE
PRESIDENT TAKES CARE OF HIM ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY OF MEETING THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
SENATORS.
IT'S WELCOME OUR SPECIAL GUEST
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP THREE
ITEMS UNDER ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
WE HAVE A RESOLUTION AS WELL AS
TO BUDGET BILLS WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF.
SENATOR UMBERG IS PREPARED TO
TAKE UP [inaudible]
HE IS.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY RELATIVE TO
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES.
SATURDAY AND CENTER I'M BURKE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS --
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION NUMBER.
ONE ADDRESSES THE ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO A RECENT DECISION BY
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PURSUE THE
DEPORTATION OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS WHO HAVE COME THE
UNITED STATES THE LAST FORTY
YEARS -- IN
A PARTICULAR THOSE WHO HAVE
ARRIVED PRIOR TO NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE THIS RESOLUTION CALLS ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STOP
ANY EFFORT. TO CHANGE THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE UNITED
STATES IN VIETNAM.
WHICH WOULDN'T COULD
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF VIETNAMESE AMERICANS DEPORTED
BACK TO VIETNAM.
DEPORTATION VIETNAMESE AMERICANS
WILL NOT UNDER ONLY UNDERMINE
THE SPIRIT OF THE AGREEMENT.
BUT ALSO MUCH LIKE OTHER
DEPORTATIONS OF THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR LONG PERIODS.
THEY'RE THE FAMILIES APART.
PARTICULARLY FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
TOGETHER FOR MANY MANY DECADES
HERE -- AS
YEAR WHERE MANY MANY SURVIVORS
OF THE VIETNAM WAR WHO'VE COME
HERE THE UNITED STATES ARE ALSO
SURVIVORS OF COMMUNIST
ATROCITIES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES NOW LIVE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA RETURNING
THEM TO VIETNAM COULD ACTUALLY
IMPACT THEIR PERSONAL SAFETY.
OF THIS PAST WEEKEND I WAS
PRIVILEGED TO BE TECH FESTIVAL
FOR THE FESTIVAL IN THE PARADE
WAS SURROUNDED BY.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PATRIOTIC AMERICANS WHO WERE
BORN IN VIETNAM OR THOSE OF
VIETNAMESE ANCESTRY.
AND SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION
TODAY WILL DEMONSTRATE THE
CALIFORNIA STANDS IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THOSE AMERICANS WHO WERE
BORN IN VIETNAM OR OF VIETNAMESE
ANCESTRY.
THOUSANDS OF HOME FOUGHT SIDE BY
SIDE BY OUR BROTHERS AND FATHERS
AND SISTERS AND MOTHERS IN
VIETNAM.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR WE DO CENTER
CHIANG THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AS A CO AUTHOR I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AJ R..
ONE CURRENTLY THERE ARE CLOSE TO
TWO MILLION PEOPLE OF VIETNAMESE
DESCENT LIVING IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AFTER THE VIETNAM WAR SOUTH
VIETNAMESE IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES AS REFUGEES
ESCAPING COMMUNIST PERSECUTION.
STARTING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THE UNITED STATES WELCOME
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES TO SEEK
ASYLUM IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
TODAY VIETNAMESE AMERICANS HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATE OF
NATURALIZATION AMONG ALL%
IMMIGRANT GROUPS AND HAVE MADE
VERY SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS
AMERICANS MERRICK IN SOCIETY AND
CULTURE.
ORANGE COUNTY IS A COUNTY WITH
HE LARGEST AMOUNT OF VIETNAESE
AMERICANS IN THE UNITED STATES
AD I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT.
A PORTION OF THAT STRONG AND
ACTIVE COMMUNITY I SUPPORT AG
ARE ONE ASK THAT WE REMEMBER HOW
IMPORTANT VIETNAMESE IMMIGRANTS
ARE TO THIS COUNTRY AND WITH
THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WOULD EITHER
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
SENATORS I TO RISE A STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR ONE IT'S A
CERTAINLY A VERY CRUEL DECISION
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. TO
BASICALLY --
SAY THAT.
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES WHO CAME
OVER TO THIS COUNTRY AFTER THE
VIETNAM WAR.
ARE WHO AFTER SUFFERING THE
TRAUMA OF THAT EXPERIENCE WHO
MIGHT HAVE MADE A MISTAKE IN
THIRTEEN YEARS HAVE BEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR DECADES.
AND NOW ARE.
ABSTAINING CONTRIBUTING CITIZENS.
SHOULD BE DEPORTED ACK TO
VIETNAM.
A COUNTRY WHO WHERE THEY MAY
ACTUALLY BE A PERSONAL RISK FOR
RETURNING AND CERTAINLY NO
LONGER HAVE THE KIND OF TIES
THAT THEY HAD WHEN THEY CAME
OVER.
AND SO CERTAINLY I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE UNITED
STATES HONOR IT'S PAST
AGREEMENTS THERE'S A REVERSAL OF
EXISTING POLICY --
THAT WAS MADE WITH THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY --
AND THAT WE'VE REVERSED CRUEL
DECISION --
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA AND THIS
COUNTRY WELCOMES IMMIGRANTS ARE
SHOULD WELCOME IMMIGRANTS THE
STATE'S CERTAINLY WELCOMES
IMMIGRANTS.
AND WE SHOULD ALSO HONOR THE
COMMITMENTS WE HAVE MADE IN THE
PAST.
AND SO I URGE AN ICE ON H. R.
ONE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER BARGES FLOORS OR SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO JOIN WITH
MY COLLEAGUES FROM SANTA ANA IN
DIAMOND BAR.
ON SUPPORTING AJ ARE NUMBER.
ONE WAS A TO SPEEDING SPEAKING
ON THIS BUT HEARING WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID.
AS HAS INSPIRED ME FURTHER BEING
FROM THE FRESNO AREA WE HAVE A
VERY VIBRANT VIETNAMESE AND
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COMMUNITY.
AND THEY HAVE CONTRIBUTED SO
MUCH TO TO WHAT WE CALL HOME.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF AGRICULTURE
IN TERMS OF BUSINESS IN TERMS OF
EDUCATION.
THEY ARE WOVEN INTO OUR
COMMUNITY AND FOR THAT WE ARE.
WE ARE FOREVER PROUD OF THE OF
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THAT
THEY'VE MET.
THE MY PRIDE IN MY PREVIOUS
CAPACITY BEFORE BECOMING A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA SENATE.
I'VE WAS A PROFESSOR OF LAW FOR
OVER TEN YEARS AND THE LAW
SCHOOL -- TO
SMALL LAW SCHOOL IN --
IN FRESH COLLEGE OF LAW WE HAD
IMMIGRATION CLINIC.
AND I GOT TO SEE WITH SOME
REGULARITY ARE THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT COME THAT WOULD COME TO THE
SCHOOL IN SEARCH OF A CLINICAL
IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
AND SO I GOT HERE EXTRAORDINARY
STORIES OF WHAT PEOPLE HAVE GONE
THROUGH TO LEAVE THEIR HOME
COUNTRY OFTEN AT GREAT PERIL TO
COME TO AMERICA.
WHEN I HEAR THESE STORIES I HAVE
A SOFT SPOT?
THAT THE CORNERSTONE OF OUR
AMERICAN LEGAL SYSTEM IS THAT IF
WE DESIGNED TO DEPORT
INDIVIDUALS WE MUST FIRST MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THEY ARE NOT BEING
EXPOSED TO UNDO HARDSHIP.
IN DANGERS UPON THE REPATRIATION.
AND I THINK IT'S CLEAR BASED ON
THE HISTORY THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT
THERE COULD BE EXTRAORDINARY
HARDSHIPS EXTRAORDINARY DANGERS
SHOULD INDIVIDUALS.
BE REPATRIATED TO THOSE HOME
COUNTRIES ESPECIALLY IN GIVEN
THE HISTORY THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCE WHETHER IT BE THE
VIETNAMESE OR THE MALL --
WE KNOW THE GOING BACK IS NOT
EASY SO BEFORE AN EVENT LIKE
THAT HAPPENS WE MUST CERTAINLY.
IMPLORE UPON OUR FEDERAL
REPRESENTATIVES THAT ANY
DECISION TO ONE DO A TREATY LIKE
THIS FIRST COME WITH --
GREAT --
SCRUTINY ON WHAT THEIR EXPOSURE
WOULD BE LIKE SHOULD THEY BE
REPATRIATED FOR THAT REASON I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR [inaudible]
THERE'S ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
LAST CALL ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER NUMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER JUST
VERY BRIEFLY THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
RESOLUTION THAT WE HOPE WILL
SEND A VERY STRONG AND UNANIMOUS
MESSAGE TO WASH DC THAT WE STAND
WITH OUR VIETNAMESE.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL. FIVE LARGEST.
I BRADFORD BY CARRIER
[inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
HI DOURADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
IA CATHY.
BYE WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
I YEAH.
THIS IS CHECK YOUR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY STERN.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
FORWARD ON TWO DIFFERENT BUDGET
BILLS.
OUR BUDGET CHAIR IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
BUT YES PLEASE I'M.
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY TWO BY
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTING TO THE STATE BUDGET
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
CENTER MITCHELL THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER PRESIDENT AB SEVENTY TWO
COLLEAGUES OF THE BUDGET BILL
THAT MAKES CHANGES TO THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN ORDER
TO TAKE EARLY ACTION ON ITEMS
RELATED TO EMERGENCY OR DISASTER
SITUATIONS.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL DOES
THE FOLLOWING IT APPROPRIATE
FIFTY MILLION FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN.
LAUNCHED TEN MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE STATE
EMERGENCY TELEPHONE NUMBER
ACCOUNT TO ENABLE THE STATE TO
BEGIN MAKING THE MEDIA
PROGRESSES PART IS AS PART OF
THE NEXT GENERATION NINE ELEVEN
SYSTEM ACTIVITIES.
IT APPROPRIATES TWENTY MILLION
TO CONTINUE EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER FUNDING AND FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RELATED TO DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS.
THIS IS NOT A WATER IS --
AN EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER
FUNDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EFFORT.
IT PROVIDES FIFTEEN MILLION TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO RETAIN
LEGAL COUNSEL TO ADDRESS PUBLIC
UTILITY IT LIABILITY ISSUES.
PROVIDES THIRTEEN POINT EXCUSE
ME PROVIDES THIRTY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION THE BACK FEEL
COUNTIES FOR PROPERTY TAX LOSSES
INCURRED AS A RESULT OF
WILDFIRES.
AND FINALLY IT CREATES THE RAPID
RESPONSE RESERVE FUND TO ADDRESS
COSTS ARE RISING FROM.
IMMIGRATION IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS AND
DEPOSITS FIVE MILLION INTO THIS
NEW ACCOUNT.
IT WAS HEARD IN FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE LAST WEEK.
IT PASSED I'M PRETTY SURE
UNANIMOUSLY VERY MEMBER
CORRECTLY WITH THAT I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
SENATORS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
THE DEAN OF THE SENATE CENTER
NIELSEN.
THIS PRESENT LEADING DOWN THE
SENATE I URGE AN AYE VOTE AND
THIS IS NECESSARY IT IS IN A
VERY AMENDING THE EIGHTEEN
BUDGET BUT IT'S CRITICAL TO MOVE
AHEAD EARLY ON BECAUSE OF THESE
ACCIDENTS.
DISASTERS THAT WE'VE SUFFERED
CALIFORNIA AND OUR NEEDS WHEN
TERMS OF WATER.
PARTICULARLY THE FIRES THE
DEVASTATION AS BEEN SOME VRY
SIGNIFICANT AND THESE ARE VERY
NECESSARY AND I WOULD URGE AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK SIR.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
ADAM BUDGET CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL BY BURGESS.
I BRADFORD.
AYE [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROVE.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WAS SO.
HIGH --
TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
BOB I KATHY.
AYE WINNER.
AYE WILK.
BY [inaudible]
I ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE FINAL BUDGET
BILLING TODAY'S DOCKET.
SENATOR MITCHELL'S PREPARED TO
PRESENT MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY THREE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACALANES PUBLIC SAFETY AND
MAKING IN PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
WELCOME BACK CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTY THREE IS A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL RELATED TO
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY THIS BILL PRIMARILY DOES
TWO THINGS IT RECREATES THE
pOPERATIONS ACCOUNT.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY SUNSET
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN
DUE TO OUR LACK OF ACTION LAST
YEAR.
THIS ACCOUNT ALLOWS FOR THE
TRANSFER OF FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES FOR EXPENSES
RELATED TO DISASTERS THAT HAVE
BEEN DECLARED BY THE GOVERNOR.
SECONDLY CLARIFIES THAT ARE
PROHIBITION ON LOGIC AND COMMON
CARRIER ENTITIES FROM HEARING
SPECIFIC CUSTOMER INFORMATION
DOES NOT APPLY THE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES WHILE CONDUCTING PUBLIC
HEALTH CIVIL RIGHTS OR CONSUMER
PROTECTION INVESTIGATIONS OR
INVESTIGATIONS UNDER THE PURVIEW
OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
IT TO PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF
THE SENATE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATORS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR LAST CALL.
HEARING SEE NINE CENTER WHICH
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL BY BURGESS.
I BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER I GROW.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
BY [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING BY.
MOORLACH.
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
STONE.
BY AMBERG [inaudible]
KATHY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE RETURNING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
IS A TIME TO ADDRESS THE SENATE
WITH YOUR JOURNEY MEMORIES.
WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO START OUR
JOURNEY MEMORIES WITH SENATOR
CHIANG.
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF THE OF THE LIVES THAT
WERE LOST IN WHAT WAS A RANDOM
BUT TRAGIC EVENT JUST A WEEK AGO.
ON FEBRUARY THIRD ROY ANDERSON
AND DAHLE YOU MARGARET MARLEY'S
LEVER ANDERSON WERE PREPARING
FOR THE SUPERBOWL UNDER YOUR
BELINDA HOME LIKE MANY OF US
THAT DAY.
BEFORE THE GAME A CESSNA FLYING
OUT OF FULLERTON SUDDENLY CAME
APART IN THE SKY.
AND SPREAD DEBRIS ACROSS FOUR
BLOCKS IN THE YORBA LINDA
NEIGHBORHOOD CLAIMING ROY AND
ALL YEARS LIVES.
AS WELL AS OUR DAUGHTER IN LAW
STACY NOREEN LEVER AND SON IN
LAW DONALD PAUL ELLIOTT.
ROY IN DALIO WERE KNOWN FOR
BEING A WARM AND WELCOMING
FAMILY.
AS HUNDREDS GATHERED TOGETHER
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER LAST
THURSDAY TO MOURN AND REMEMBER
THE VICTIMS AT A CANDLELIGHT
VIGIL WARNING ONE MOURNER PUT IT
SUCCINCTLY.
THE WORLD LOST SOME VERY GOOD
PEOPLE. FIFTEEN DONALD WERE
CONSTITUENTS OF THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM RIVERSIDE IN THE THIRTY
FIRST DISTRICT AND I EXTEND MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO YOUR
COMMUNITY AS WELL.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING IN THE MEMORY OF ROY LEE
ANDERSON.
DOLLY MARLEY'S LEVER ANDERSON
THE CEILING NOREEN LEVER AND
DONALD PAUL ELLIOTT.
SEARCHING PLEASE PASS DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILIES
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING A FOR
MEMBERS WE TACTIC TURN THE FLOOR
OVER NOW TO SENATOR JACKSON'S
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I STAND IN ASKS THAT
YOU JOIN ME IN OUR MEMORIALIZING
IN IN.
THE ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
ONE OF THE MOST INTERESTING MAN
IN THE WORLD.
HIS NAME WAS GUY WEBSTER.
GUY WAS BORN IN HOLLYWOOD.
TO OF A FELLOW NAMED PAUL
FRANCIS WEBSTER WHO WAS ONE OF
THE COUNTRY'S GREAT LYRICISTS
WHO.
RECEIVE FOURTEEN ACADEMY AWARD
NOMINATIONS AND THREE ACADEMY
AWARDS FOR SONGS THAT SOME OF US
OLDER FOLKS MIGHT REMEMBER
THINGS LIKE.
THE SHADOW OF YOUR SMILE.
LOVE IS A MANY AND SECRET LOVE.
THE GUY WAS HIS OWN MAN AND IN
SPITE OF GROWING UP IN THE
OPULENCE IN THE GLAMOUR.
OF HOLLYWOOD HIMSELF WAS AN
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL.
MAN OF MUSIC.
AND ART I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT HERE FOR MANY OF YOU.
THIS WS A COVER TO A CALENDAR
BUT IN THE OLD DAYS WHEN VOTE
RECORDS WERE VINYL.
THESE WERE REPRESENTATIVE
USUALLY OF THE COVERS THE
JACKETS TO SEVENTY EIGHT RPM
RECORDS.
GUY WEBSTER WAS AN INNOVATOR IN
THE FIELD ALL OF THESE KINDS OF
ARTWORK AND IF YOU RECALL
FREQUENTLY PEOPLE WOULD BUY A
RECORD ALBUM BECAUSE OF THE
COVER.
MANY OF THOSE COVERS.
WERE THE WORK OF GOD WEBSTER.
GOING FROM PEOPLE.
LIKE SIMON AND GARFUNKEL.
BOB DYLAN JANIS JOPLIN MICK
JAGGER JIMI HENDRIX THE DOORS
THE ROLLING STONES THE MAMAS AND
THE PAPAS THE BEACH BOYS THE
BYRDS CHICAGO AND HUNDREDS OF
OTHERS.
THEIR ALBUM COLORS A COVERS WERE
HIS WORK.
HE WENT ON TO HAVE A FORTY YEAR
CAREER IN THIS --
BUSINESS IN THIS ARTISTIC
ENDEAVOR HE WAS THE PRIMARY
CELEBRITY PHOTOGRAPHER FOR
COUNTLESS WORLDWIDE MAGAZINES
WAS ABLE TO CAPTURE THE ESSENCE
OF PEOPLE LIKE IGOR STRAVINSKY
BARBRA STREISAND CANDICE BERGEN.
EVEN BILL CLINTON AND RONALD
REAGAN WERE AMONG THOSE WHOSE
PHOTOGRAPHS AND IMAGES HE
PURPOSE --
WAS ABLE TO CAPTURE.
BUT HE WAS A RENAISSANCE MAN AS
WELL.
AND IN ADDITION TO BEING AN
EXTRAORDINARY TENNIS PLAYER AND
I CAN VOUCH FOR THAT BECAUSE HE
AND I WON A COUPLE MIXED DOUBLES
TOURNAMENTS TOGETHER.
BUT HE WAS ALSO APPARENTLY A
SCRATCH GOLFER.
WHO PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
CHALLENGE MISTER BRADFORD TO A%
PRETTY HARD TO GAME OF GOLF HAD
THEY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET?
BUT I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO ME.
TO AND HE ALSO BEING A MAN OF SO
MANY DIFFERENT INTERESTS WAS ONE
OF THE LEADING A COLLECTORS OF
GREAT ITALIAN MOTORCYCLES.
AND IN THE COURSE OF ONE PERIOD
OF TIME HE OWN TWO HUNDRED OF
THE FINEST ITALIAN MOTORCYCLES
IN THE WORLD AND KEPT THEM.
IN ACTUALLY MUSEUM THAT HE HAD
CREATED ON HIS PROPERTY AND I
REMEMBER ONE AFTERNOON AFTER MY
HUSBAND AND I HAD SPENT THE
AFTERNOON WITH WITH GUY IN LEóN.
I IS WE WERE LEAVING THERE WAS A
BIG BUS OF VISITORS FROM JAPAN.
WHO CAME TO SEE HIS MOTORCYCLE
COLLECTION HE WAS MOST PROUD OF
THAT BUT IT WASN'T A HOBBY IT
WAS ACTUALLY AN ARTISTIC
ENDEAVOR HE MADE SURE THAT THESE
MOTORCYCLES WERE?
AUTHENTIC THAT THEY WERE
DRIVABLE USABLE IN FACT HE USED
TO TAKE SMALL TRIPS FROM ALL
HIGH -- TO
BOSTON TO CAPTURE A FERRY.
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD WHERE HE
FREQUENTLY SPENT THE SUMMER.
HE WAS ALSO A ROCK CONTOUR WHO
COULD WEAVE STORIES ABOUT HIS
LIFE AND THE PEOPLE HE HAD MET.
THERE WERE SO INTRIGUING THAT HE
FREQUENTLY WOULD HOLD FOR TEN
HOLD COURT AND YOU KNOW HIGH AT
A COFFEE SHOP FOR YOUNG AND OLD
WOULD COME. TO HEAR ABOUT SOME
OF THE EXTRAORDINARY --
AND FASCINATING X. WORLD'S MOST
FAMOUS PEOPLE.
BUT IN SPITE OF ALL OF THIS
OPULENCE AND GLAMOUR IN HIS LIFE
HE WAS ONE OF THE SIMPLEST
PEOPLE I NEVER HEARD HIM SPEAK.
UNCOMPLIMENTARY WORD ABOUT
ANYONE HE WAS REALLY AN
EXTRAORDINARY MAN AND SO I WOULD
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME.
IN SENDING OUR CONDOLENCES TO
LEóN HIS WIFE AND HIS CHILDREN.
AND I'M SURE HE'S UP THERE IN
THE GREAT BEYOND REGALING PEOPLE
WITH THE STORIES OF A LIFE WELL
LIVED.
THANK YOU MISTER PROTECT THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATE JACKSON THOSE
WONDERFUL AND PLEASE ACCEPT OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR STONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT THAN
AND MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW ITS --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE AS WE WE ALL
AGE.
AND WHEN YOU GET TO VIEW MY AGE
USE YOU START SEEING SOME --
FRIENDS THAT HAVE HEALTH ISSUES
AND TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY EARLY --
MANY OF US YOU KNOW.
INCLUDING MYSELF SOMETIMES WE
TAKE LIFE FOR GRANTED YOU NEVER
KNOW.
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO GET CALLED?
I WASN'T FEELING WELL LAST WEEK
IN.
WHEN TO GO SEE OUR GREAT NURSE
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITAL OF
HAVING A FEVER EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT?
WASN'T IT WASN'T GETTING BETTER.
AND FINALLY MY WIFE --
INSISTED --
THAT I WENT TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.
AND THINKING I WAS JUST HAVING
AN INFECTION.
I HAD A DOCTOR THE CAME IN AND
SAID -- THIS
OR STONE YOUR YOUR BLOOD TEST
CAME OUT GOOD AND THEY CAME OUT
BAD.
WE DID HAVE A PROBLEM WITH YOUR
THOUGHT OF HAVING AN INFECTION
BUT YOUR TROPONIN LEVELS ARE
ELEVATED.
WHICH MEANS THAT YOU MAY BE
HAVING A HEART ATTACK OR YOU MAY
HAVE HAD A HEART ATTACK.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET YOU
TO THE HOSPITAL FOR YOUR BLOOD
TO DO A HEART CATH AND DO --
ANGIOGRAM.
AND I BRING THIS TO YOU BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE SOMETIMES SWEAT A
LOT OF THE SMALL STUFF.
BUT THIS THE BIG STUFF WHEN YOU
THINK YOU'RE HEALTHY AND YOU END
UP IN A HOSPITAL YOU'RE NOT
KNOWING WHERE THAT YOU'RE GOING.
TO SEE YOUR DAUGHTER THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE TWINS AND FIVE
MONTHS OR SEE.
YOUR DAUGHTER Là THAT'S GOING
TO HAVE A DAUGHTER IN A MONTH
AND A HALF.
I WAS VERY PLEASED THAT.
THE DIAGNOSIS WAS --
THE CARDIAC INFECTION A VIRAL
INFECTION OF THE HEART IT WAS NO
HEART DAMAGE IT WAS NO.
ATHEROSCLEROSIS HEART PLAQUE I
WAS VERY PLEASED TO BE RELEASED
FROM THE HOSPITAL.
BUT I BRING THIS TO YOUR
ATTENTION BECAUSE IT'S VERY SAD
WHEN WE WE LOSE SOMEBODY VERY
CLOSE TO US ESPECIALLY SOMEBODY
THAT MAYBE A MENTOR OF OURS AND
AND THAT HAPPENED THIS.
THIS LAST WEEK AS I WITH GREAT
SADNESS ANNOUNCE THAT ONE OF MY
VERY DEAR FRIENDS [inaudible]
RON ROBERTS.
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY FOURTH
ON WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN HIS
FIFTIETH WEDDING ANNIVERSARY.
HE WAS A CAREER HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICER.
AND RON WAS ASSIGNED TO THE TO
MAKE AN AREA IN THE MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AND MOVED HIS FAMILY
THERE.
HE RETIRED FROM THE C. H. P. AND
NINETEEN NINETY SIX RON SERVE
THE PEOPLE TO MECCA FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
FIRST AS A TRAFFIC COMMISSIONER.
NINETEEN NINETY THE YEAR AFTER
OUR CITY OF TEMECULA CORPORATE
IT IN THEM FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS
ON THE TO MAKE THE CITY COUNCIL.
RON AND I WERE.
BOTH FIRST ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
TOGETHER.
INDIA THAT BEING THERE FOR FIVE
TERMS.
I DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE WE ARE
ELECTED BUT WE BECAME VERY CLOSE
FRIENDS WE SHARED SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR LIVES TOGETHER
AND WE WERE THERE.
DURING SOME VERY GOOD TIMES AND
SOME [inaudible]
BAD TIMES.
WORKING WITH HIM WE HELP BILL TO
MICHAEL INTO THE EXCITING
VIBRANT FAMILY FRIENDLY
COMMUNITY THAT IT IS TODAY.
HIS FINGERPRINTS ARE ALL OVER TO
MACULA THE REVITALIZATION OF OUR
OLD TOWN TEMECULA WHICH IS IN
SHAMBLES.
WHEN WE WERE ELECTED?
THE BEAUTIFUL DUCK POND THAT HE
CREATE THAT SERVES AS THE
ENTRANCE TO THE CITY PROBABLY
THE MOST VALUABLE PIECE OF
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY.
IN OUR CITY.
AND THE PROMENADE MALL THE WE
HELP BRING TO THE CITY OF
TEMECULA RATHER THAN A DISCOUNT
RETAILER.
AND THE BEAUTIFUL LIBRARY THE
FARTS HE HE IF HE FOUGHT SO HARD
TO BRING TO THE CITY.
COMING UP TO SACRAMENTO FOR
NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS TO GET STATE
FUNDING.
AND HE FINALLY GOT IT AND WE ARE
IN HIM.
BY CALLING AT THE RONALD H.
ROBERTS TO MACULA PUBLIC LIBRARY
PRIOR TO HIS DEMISE.
THE LIBRARY MEANS THE BUSIEST OF
ALL THIRTY FIVE LIBRARIES IN THE
CITY TO MACULA.
WHEN I WAS ELECTED AS RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR?
I WAS VERY HONORED WHEN YOU JOIN
MY STAFF.
HIS EXPERIENCE AS A CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICER.
AND HIS EXPERTISE IN ALL AREAS
OF TRANSPORTATION PROVIDED
INVALUABLE SERVICE TO OUR STAFF.
FOR TEN GOOD YEARS.
HIS EXPERTISE ALSO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OVER AS LONG PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER RON SERVED ON NUMEROUS
COMMITTEES AND COMMISSIONS
INCLUDING THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
WESTERN COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS.
CHAIRMAN OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
CHAIRMAN OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL RAIL
AUTHORITY.
ALSO KNOWN AS MATTER LINK AND
ALSO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS.
WHERE HE WAS?
A WONDERFUL --
AMENITY TO THE PLANNING OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING SYSTEMS
AND VIRTUALLY 50% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION.
BUT RUNS A GREAT INHERENT
ABILITY WAS HIS ABILITY TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
AND HIS WISE COUNSEL CONTRIBUTED
GREATLY TO THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR THE PEOPLE INTO MACULA AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT THEY ENJOY
TODAY.
MY THOUGHTS ARE WITH HIS WIFE
JEANNIE IS SON RON JUNIOR
DAUGHTER WINDY AND IT'S FIVE
GRAND CHILDREN.
MY FRIENDS HE WAS SIMPLY ONE OF
THE BEST.
A GOOD MAN [inaudible]
RON ROBERTS.
IN A MAKES ME PAUSE WHEN I TELL
MY KIDS I TELL MY WIFE AND I
TELL MY FRIENDS.
INCLUDING MANY OF YOU.
BUT I LOVE YOU ALL AND I ENJOY
SERVING A PART OF MY LIFE WITH
YOU AND EACH AND EVERY LIFE HERE
IS PRECIOUS EVEN THOUGH WE MAY
DISAGREE VIGOROUSLY.
ON MANY ISSUES.
SO I'D LIKE TO SAY.
REST IN PEACE MY DEAR FRIEND.
UNTIL WE BRACE AGAIN.
I LOVE YOU MY FRIEND RON ROBERTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER STONE
IN PLEASE PASS ALONG OUR DEEP
CONDOLENCES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
INTERNAL MEMORY FOR AN AMERICAN
HERO [inaudible]
CENTERS CAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I ASKED THAT
THE STATE SENATE.
A JUROR IN MEMORY.
OF OAKLAND RAISED BASEBALL
LEGEND [inaudible]
AND FIRST.
IN MUCH BASEBALL HISTORY
[inaudible]
FRANK ROBINSON.
FRANK ROBINSON WAS BORN IN TEXAS.
HE PASSED WAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH
IN LOS ANGELES TO JUST LAST WEEK
EIGHTY THREE YEARS OLD.
HE WAS BORN IN TEXAS BUT THE
MOVE DOES A LITTLE LITTLE KID TO
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA.
AND THEN QUICKLY IS MOTHER MOVED
HIM TO OAKLAND WEST OAKLAND
WHERE HE GREW UPAND WENT TO
SCHOOL.
ASPHALT FIELDS OF OAKLAND PARKS
HE THEN ATTENDED.
OAKLAND'S MCCLEMENTS HIGH SCHOOL.
WHERE HE PLAYED BOTH BASKETBALL
AND BASEBALL ALONG SIDE WITH
FUTURE NBA LEGEND BILL RUSSELL?
HE PLAYED WITH MANY OTHER LATER
BASEBALL GREATS ALL WHO LEARNED
BASEBALL IN OAKLAND.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE AT
EIGHTEEN HE SIGNED WITH THE
CINCINNATI REDS AND HE WENT ON
TO HAVE A TWENTY ONE SEASON
CAREER.
BUT IT IS ONLY APPROPRIATE
DURING THIS BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
TO POINT OUT.
SOME OF FRANK ROBINSON'S
ACHIEVEMENTS.
HE WAS THE ONLY PLAYER IN
BASEBALL HISTORY TO BE NAMED MVP
FOR BOTH LEAKS.
HE PLAYED FOURTEEN ALL STAR
GAMES HE WAS A TWO TIME WORLD
SERIES CHAMP INCLUDING THE MVP
FOR THE NINETEEN SIXTY SIX WORLD
SERIES WHERE THE ORIOLES SWEPT
THE DODGERS --
WELL WHO ROBINSON LATER PLAYED
FOR HE PLAYED FOR THE DODGERS AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA ANGELS.
ROBINSON HIT FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX HOME RUNS WHEN HE WAS
INDUCTED INTO THE BASEBALL HALL
OF FAME.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT MADE
HIM THE FOURTH HIGHEST HOME RUN
HITTER.
IN BASEBALL HISTORY.
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHEN HE
WAS STILL A PLAYER WITH THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS.
HE WAS ALSO MADE AS A PLAYER THE
FIRST BLACK MANAGER.
AND IT WAS MANAGER OF THE
INDIANS.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE HE WAS NAY
MANAGER AS THE SF GIANTS.
WHICH MADE HIM.
THE FIRST AFRICAN MAYOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND THE FIRST PERSON IN
BASEBALL HISTORY TO MANAGE BOTH
THE NATIONAL.
AND AMERICAN LEAGUE TEAM.
HE LATER WENT ON TO MANAGE THE
ORIOLES THE EXPOS IN THE
NATIONALS.
AS THE MANAGER OF THE SF GIANTS
HE SIGNED JOE MORGAN.
WHO WAS A FELLOW OAKLAND RAISED
BASEBALL PLAYER?
MORGAN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TO HIT
THE HOME RUN.
SORRY LA THAT ELIMINATED THE
DOCTORS FROM THE PLAYOFFS THAT
YEAR.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
PRESIDENT GEORGE BUSH.
GAVE FRANK ROBINSON THE MEDAL OF
HONOR.
THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM SKEWS ME THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM
[inaudible]
ROBINSON WAS.
INITIALLY A RELUCTANT ACTIVIST
IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
BUT WHEN HE MOVED TO BALTIMORE.
HE BECAME VERY VERY ENGAGED IN
ACTIVE.
AND SPOKE OUT AGAINST THE
SEGREGATED HOUSING AND RACIST
REAL ESTATE PRACTICES THAT HE
DIRECTLY EXPERIENCED AND SAW
RAMPANT IN BALTIMORE.
HE THEN WAS ALSO OUT SPOKEN IN
QUESTIONING WHY WHITE PITCHERS
WERE NOT BEING OPENLY REBUKED
FOR BASICALLY DIRECT IT
PURPOSEFULLY HITTING.
BLACK BATTERS.
WE WILL ALL MOURN FRANK
ROBINSON'S PASSING.
BUT HE WILL BE ESPECIALLY
[inaudible]
MISSED BY.
HIS WIFE BARBARA HIS DAUGHTER
MICHELLE IN HIS SON FRANK KEVIN.
I ASK WITH THAT WE ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY.
THE SENATE SKINNER CENTER
BRADFORD ON THE SIDE OF YES I TO
THINK HE WAS PRESIDENT JUST WANT
TO ADD MY VOICE IN A DURING
MEMORY OF MISTER ROBINSON I
INDIVIDUAL THAT I HAD THE
PLEASURE MEETING.
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND IT
WASN'T ON A BASEBALL FIELD OF
ALL PLACES IT WAS THAT THE
FORMAT THE LAKER GAME BECAUSE HE
WAS A BIG.
BASKETBALL FAN AND HE WOULD
ALWAYS STAND IN THE TUNNEL AND
JUST BE THE MOST GRACIOUS QUIET
INDIVIDUAL.
NOT UNDERSTAND IF YOU DIDN'T
KNOW WE WAS OF ALL THESE MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS SENATOR
SKINNER CLEARLY IDENTIFY I GREW
UP PLAYING BASEBALL AND AS I
STATED A LAST WEEK WHEN I DURING
THE MEMORY OF ONE OF MY FORMER
PLAYERS.
COACH FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AND
FIRST BASS HE WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN I REMEMBER
PLAYING FIRST BASE AND I SAID IF
IT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR FRANK
ROBINSON IT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME.
AND MY MOTHER COULD PRY TELL THE
STORY OF THIS ONE OF A COMBINE
ALL STAR GLOVE.
THE CAME OUT IN THE EARLY
SEVENTIES AND HAD TOOL
AUTOGRAPHS ONE BEING FRANK
ROBINSON WAS RED WHITE AND BLUE.
AND I REMEMBER MY MOTHER DRIVING
ALL OVER TOWN TRYING TO FIND
THIS GLOVE.
AND FINALLY FIND A AND IT WAS
THE HIGHLIGHT OF MY PLAYING
CAREER AND EVERYBODY WAS ENVIOUS
OF THE FACT THAT I HAD THIS VERY
EXPENSIVE GLOVE AT THE TIME.
BUT HIT THE AUTOGRAPH OF FRANK
ROBINSON AND BROOKS ROBINSON AND
IT'S SO ON YES AS A CHILD --
INDIVIDUAL RELIVING HIS
CHILDHOOD I THINK MISS ROBBINS
FOR ALL THIS WONDERFUL
CONTRIBUTIONS NOT ONLY ON THE
BASEBALL FIELD THE TIMES WE
SHARED AT THE LATER GAMES AS
WELL.
HE WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD.
MEMBERS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WE HAVE NO FURTHER
ADJOURN IN MEMORIES.
SENATOR BAYH LEADER BATES UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS --
WE HAVE A BRIEF REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE* LOUNGE AT A
GERMAN THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH LEADER BATES ANY ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS CLASS CALL.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
CENTER RACK INCIDENCES CLEAR
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT JUST
A COUPLE OF THINGS --
TOMORROW OF COURSE FEBRUARY
TWELFTH AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK WE
WILL.
HAVE THE STATE OF THE STATE BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE ALL OF OUR SENATORS --
AT TEN THIRTY MAYBE TO MEET HERE
IN CAN WALK OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
AS A SENATE BODY --
IT WOULD BE A NICE SHOW OF
SENATE SOLIDARITY --
IF WE'RE ABLE TO JOIN TOGETHER
TO DO THAT SO I INVITE YOU TO
JOIN ME HERE TOMORROW TEN THIRTY
SO WE CAN MARK WALK OVER
TOGETHER --
AND HAVEN'T SAID THAT --
A LOT DONE TODAY RECOGNIZING
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE --
AND ALSO A COUPLE OF REALLY
IMPORTANT ITEMS SO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR A LITTLE BIT
LONGER DAY BUT OBVIOUSLY THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE SAID.
WE WILL AFTER TOMORROW OF COURSE
WE WILL THEN RECONVENE ON FRIDAY
NOT THURSDAY ON FRIDAY PROMPTLY
AT NINE AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRO TEM
REMINDER ALL SENATORS PLEASE
REPORT OF FLOOR TOMORROW TUESDAY
AT TEN THIRTY THERE'LL BE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING SESSION
THE SENATE IS ADJOURNED